[Music]
on
august 28 1963 martin luther king jr
delivered his
i have a dream speech at the march on
washington for jobs and freedom that day
nearly a quarter million people gathered
on the national mall to demand an end to
the discrimination
segregation violence and economic
exclusion
black people still faced across the
united states
none of it would have been possible
without the march's chief organizer
a man named bayern rustin rustin grew up
in a quaker household and began
peacefully protesting racial segregation
in high school
he remained committed to pacifism
throughout his life and was jailed
in 1944 as a conscientious objector to
world war ii
during his two-year imprisonment he
protested the segregated facilities from
within
wherever rustin went he organized and
advocated
and was constantly attuned to the
methods groups and people
who could help further messages of
equality he joined the communist party
when black american civil rights were
one of its priorities
but soon became disillusioned by the
party's authoritarian leanings and left
in 1948 he traveled to india to learn
the peaceful resistance strategies
of the recently assassinated mahatma
gandhi
he returned to the united states armed
with strategies for peaceful protest
including civil disobedience he began to
work with martin luther king jr in 1955
and shared these ideas with him as
king's prominence increased
rustin became his main advisor as well
as a key strategist in the broader civil
rights movement he brought his
organizing expertise
to the 1956 bus boycotts in montgomery
alabama
in fact he had organized and
participated in a transportation protest
that helped inspire the boycotts almost
a decade before
his largest scale organizing project
came in 1963
when he led the planning for the
national march on washington
the possibility of riots that could
injure marchers and undermine their
message of peaceful protest
was a huge concern rusted not only
worked with the d.c police and hospitals
to prepare
but organized and trained a volunteer
force of 2000 security marshals
in spite of his deft management some of
the other organizers did not want ruston
to march in front
with other leaders from the south
because of his homosexuality
despite these slights rustin maintained
his focus
and on the day of the march he delivered
the marchers demands in a speech
directed at president john f kennedy the
march itself proceeded smoothly without
any violence
it has been credited with helping pass
the 1964 civil rights act
which ended segregation in public places
and banned employment discrimination
and the 1965 voting rights act which
outlawed discriminatory voting practices
in spite of his decades of service
rustin's positions on certain political
issues were unpopular among his peers
some thought he wasn't critical enough
of the vietnam war or that he was too
eager to collaborate with the political
establishment
including the president and congress
others were uncomfortable with his
former communist affiliation
but ultimately both his belief in
collaboration with the government and
his membership to the communist party
had been driven by his desire to
maximize tangible gains and liberties
for black americans
and to do so as quickly as possible
ruston was passed over for several
influential roles in the 1960s and 70s
but he never stopped his activism in the
1980s
he publicly came out as gay and was
instrumental in drawing attention to the
aids crisis
until his death in 1987. in 2013
50 years after the march on washington
president barack obama
posthumously awarded him the
presidential medal of freedom
praising rustin's march towards true
equality
no matter who we are or who we love
fired rustin famously said that every
community needs a group of angelic
troublemakers
people willing to stand up and speak out
against the status quo
and students around the world have
always been uniquely positioned to do
just that
become a part of ted ed's free student
talks program
to practice putting your ideas visions
and hopes
into words that can spread across the
globe and affect change
and while you're at it meet other
passionate students from over 130
countries
who are claiming their space and their
futures visit ed.ted.com
student talks to get started